[Music]
welcome back
okay so uh this is i think the third
lecture in this series on complex
analysis
we have introduced what we mean by a
complex number a number with a real and
an imaginary part
we have started to talk about complex
variables this variable z equals x plus
iy
and now i want to talk about functions
of a complex variable functions of z
just like we have normal real valued
functions cosine of x sine of x e to the
x logarithm of x we're going to have
functions of this complex variable so
their inputs will be complex numbers and
their outputs will be complex numbers
and we want to think about functions of
z so that we can think about doing
calculus
on these functions these functions are
are going to end up being the solutions
of our ordinary and partial differential
equations they are going to be functions
that represent things like uh you know
the wave
uh the wave equation in quantum
mechanics and things like that so
they're going to have very real
interpretations in physics and so i need
to introduce what are the properties of
these functions what do these functions
look like
what are the things that are the same
about these functions
that are similar to real valued
functions and what is different what's
weird about these functions okay so
that's what we're going to talk about
now
probably the one i like to
introduce the first are these
kind of power functions so
powers of a complex
variable z
so
z to the n
is a function of z
uh just like a real valued x squared you
can have z squared
and this is going to equal
r
times
cosine theta plus i sine
theta
quantity
to the nth power
and so sometimes i'm going to use the
polar form of the complex variable z in
terms of its radius
and its phase angle so maybe i'll just
draw a little picture here
um
if this is the real value of z
and this is the imaginary value of z
then
my little z value here
can be written in terms of r
and theta a radius and theta theta in
this two-dimensional complex plane
or it can be represented in terms of the
real part x
and the imaginary part y so you can say
x equal z equals x plus iy
x plus iy
or it can be written in terms of r its
radius
inclined at an angle theta and so here i
you know i usually like the polar form
when i'm doing things like multiplying
because it's easier to to take powers
uh in polar form
good so i'll just label these as i go
this is a kind of the
power function
where i literally just take the power
of z
and we're eventually going to build up
to the taylor series we can do full
taylor series expansions things like e
to the z sine of z cosine of z in terms
of their taylor series but we're going
to start with just finite powers that's
a totally valid function
another function that's interesting uh
would be
a power series maybe i'll alternate
colors here
so a power series would be something
like uh a sum
from k equals 0 to n of some coefficient
a k
times z to the power k
so if we if this is a function of z
squared and z cubed and z to the fourth
are functions then i can add up those
functions with some you know complex
coefficient ak
so these are
what are we going to call these we're
going to call these power series
okay power series
uh i can also do things like create a
rational function i could say that you
know um and i should probably call these
f of z's i should probably say that this
is
uh you know
f of z equals
f
of z
equals
and then you know i can do other things
like i can have f of z equals
a rational function basically a ratio
of two different
two different power series k equals zero
to n
times a k z to the k
divided by the sum
let's say of j equals zero to m these
don't have to have the same order
uh b uh subscript j to the z z to the
shoot z to the j power
z to the j power
okay so this is a rational function
again just like i can have a rational
function of x a real valued rational
function i can have a rational function
of
of z this is a rational
function
i'm going to start getting into the
exotic ones in a minute sines and
cosines logarithms hyperbolic sines
hyperbolic cosines exponentials things
like that
the last one i want to introduce is the
taylor series right which is essentially
a power this this power series where now
n goes to infinity
so now i'm going to have
f of z or z
equals the sum
from k equals 0 to infinity
of a
k
and here i'm going to also make it so
that it's a little more general it
doesn't have to be
um
a maclaurin series where it's expanded
about z equals zero we're going to say
that this is z minus some z naught
to the power k
so this could be centered at any point z
naught and i'm going to take an infinite
sum of powers of z expanded about that
point
and just like in real valued functions
this is our taylor
our taylor series
good
okay
and so some of these functions are
better behaved than others so these
power functions just z to the 2 z to the
three z to the four those are very well
behaved functions
uh they are continuous and smooth
everywhere the notion of a derivative
makes sense you can do calculus on these
uh these are called analytic functions
and they have really really nice
properties um the sums of these the
finite sums these power series are also
really nice quantities really well
defined smooth functions
these expansions here
if this converges if this has a
convergent taylor series then these are
also really nicely defined analytic
functions so functions like e to the z
cosine of z sine of z are going to be
nicely defined convergent taylor series
and so what i mean by that
is the taylor series uh is convergent
the taylor series
um
is kind of well defined
if uh
is only convergent
convergent
and this is just like in real value
calculus remember you exe you write down
a taylor series and you see does this
series does this infinite sum actually
add up to something that's a finite
number
uh and for what values of z is it
convergent so this taylor series is only
convergent if
this limit l equals the limit as k goes
to infinity
of
a k plus 1 divided by a k and these are
complex numbers so i'm just going to
take the ratio and then take the the
kind of radius or the norm of those
if this exists
and
then we would say then
f converges
for
z minus z naught for a radius around
that z naught
less than one over
l this is the radius of convergence so
essentially there would be
you know some z naught
and there is some radius here which is
you know one over l where l is this
limit
so if i am if i am within a radius
of convergence where this taylor series
converges where this property is true
then this taylor series converges
anywhere within that radius okay and
again what that means is that my
function is smooth continuously
differentiable i can take derivatives of
this function and it's a so-called nice
analytic function
in that radius of convergence so i'm
going to have a whole video on what it
means to be an analytic function these
are super super important functions
that essentially
are the solution of laplace's equation
from partial differential equations and
it's a really really special and
important class of complex functions
that have convergent taylor series okay
and if the taylor series converges
everywhere we would say that it is an
entire function entire like it's
entirely convergent
this is just nomenclature complex
analysts use
good okay so i want to give you an
example of how we would compute a
convergent taylor series and how we
would kind of run this test just like we
would run this test in a calculus class
i'm going to show you how to do it for
complex functions too
um
i think the easiest complex function to
try this out on would be the complex
exponential function
so let's try this uh let's try the
exponential
and the exponential function is uh e to
the z
equals i wrote this down in the last
lecture this equals the sum from uh k
equals zero
to infinity
of
z to the power k
divided by
k factorial this is a
k factorial
and so that
a k coefficient is 1 over k factorial
this means essentially
um that a
k equals 1 over
k factorial that's the coefficient out
front of this
and so what we want to do to check the
convergence so we're going to check uh l
equals
this limit sorry my pen is squeaky i
know that drives some of you crazy
of k goes to infinity
of a k plus 1 divided by ak
okay and i got to be really really
careful
a k plus 1
is 1 over k plus 1
factorial that's
a k plus 1
times
k factorial that's
1 over a k
1 over a k is k factorial
and that equals so um
1 over k plus 1 factorial times k
factorial all of the k factorial inside
of here
cancel out remember k factorial is k
times k minus 1 times k minus 2 times
dot dot times 3 times 2 times 1.
so
k plus 1 factorial is just k factorial
times another k plus 1.
so the first k factorial cancel out and
i just get 1 over k plus 1.
i don't need the absolute value anymore
but i'll keep it and we're taking the
limit as k goes to infinity
and the limit as k goes to infinity of 1
over k
is
[Music]
0.
so essentially this l uh
this taylor series is only convergent if
this l exists if it's bounded it
definitely exists the number zero
and f converges for everything within a
radius of one over that number l and
kind of one over zero is infinity so the
radius you know the radius of
convergence
is infinite
that means that this exponential
function
its taylor series
converges everywhere for every single z
you can write down in the complex plane
a bajillion
you know like 5 million plus 10 billion
i
that will have a convergent e to that
number if z equals 5000 plus 9000 i e to
that number exists
because this has an infinite radius of
convergence for every z in the complex
plane e to the z is a well-defined
quantity
so that's just one example of a function
that has a well-defined radius of
convergence which means it has a
a convergent taylor series which means
it is analytic everywhere
again i'm just going to spit out all
these these words because your complex
analysis teacher is probably using these
words all the time too
and because this is analytic everywhere
and has a convergent taylor series that
means it's an entire function this
function is called entire
let's write it
this is an entire
function
okay
good um
good okay so those are just some
functions that we use all of the time
things like you know z squared z cubed z
to the fourth a sum of those polynomials
an infinite sum of those polynomials if
that taylor series converges like it
does for the exponential function for
science sine of z cosine of z will show
that those also converge
hyperbolic sine hyperbolic cosine things
like those
good um
maybe i will give a few more just
interesting facts here so i'm going to
revisit
the power function so we're going to
z to the n here
and remember when we have
z equals
i'm essentially going to recopy this
here it equals r
cosine of theta
plus i sine of theta
and that means that this is r e to the i
theta by euler's formula euler's formula
allows me to take e to the i theta and
write it as cosine theta plus i sine
theta that was the last lecture
and so that means that
z to the nth power
is just r to the n e to the i
and theta okay and we already wrote this
down in the last lecture this is de
moivre's
formula here so this is r to the n
times cosine n theta
plus i sine
and
theta the reason i'm rewriting this here
is because i want to show you kind of in
a picture
uh what this looks like so if i have my
complex plane
where this is real
and this is imaginary this is my complex
plane
then if i have
some z variable
that is let's say here we have z
equals r e to the i theta it has some
length
and it has some
let's say some theta and some radius
then if i look at z squared i am going
to square the radius and double the
angle
so it's really easy to take powers in
the complex plane when you think about
them in polar coordinates
so z squared let's see if i can actually
draw this
z squared
is going to equal r squared e to the i
two theta
so this is two theta
and this is r
squared and similarly r cubed
z cubed is uh it's gonna be a little
hard to write this
r cubed e to the i three theta so this
is going to have r cubed as the radius
and the angle is going to be
three theta and you're seeing that i'm
having a hard time drawing perfectly
this angle which is three theta but you
can take my word for it that's that's
what you would get
okay so these functions here are really
easy to understand again when you think
about them in polar coordinates because
uh the radius
gets you know x uh taken to that power
so z to the n
has a
radius to the n
and its angle it's kind of phase angle
in the complex plane is multiplied by n
of that z variable
good
okay what else do i want to show you
there's probably a few more things um
we're getting close to finished
um
there is a super super super important
function the complex logarithm so the
complex exponential
is really easy to understand it's
exactly like the real valued exponential
it just has this convergent taylor
series except now instead of plugging in
real numbers for z i can plug in any
complex number i like and it converges
everywhere
there is the analog of the complex
logarithm the complex logarithm is a
little bit more
exotic and in fact it's such an
important function and it's so kind of
interesting and strange i'm going to
have a whole lecture on the complex
logarithm
so log
of z
you're going to have to stay tuned okay
this is uh
the next lecture is going to be all
about the log of z
but i'll tell you about a couple more
fun functions uh that i think about a
lot
one would be the trigonometric functions
so our trig
functions
are things like um
sine of z
and cosine of z
uh and so the sine of z and cosine of z
there's lots and lots of ways of
defining them i could define them using
the
taylor series like i could take the real
value taylor series of sine of x and i
could replace x with the complex
variable z and that would be one fine
definition of sine i would have to check
that it has a convergent taylor series
everywhere that's easy to do that's a
good homework problem for you
and at least the first part of what the
taylor series is we covered in the last
lecture
but another way to write this which i
think is kind of nice is in terms of
these complex exponentials
so sine of z is e to the i z
minus e to the minus i z
divided by 2 i
so you can confirm that if you take the
taylor series e to the i z and the
taylor series e to the minus i z and you
subtract them
all of the even terms will cancel out
and you'll only be left with the odd
terms
and if you divide by 2i you'll be left
with the taylor series for sine of z
similarly for cosine of z this is i'm
assuming you add these
i'm not even going to look at my notes
because that kind of has to be true if
this kills all the even terms this will
keep all of the even terms and instead
of dividing by
2i
i can't remember if this is divided by
2i or 2.
two
question mark okay so there are these
formulas though essentially your trig
functions also can be expressed in terms
of these exponentials
uh you can sum them up
please verify this is a really good
homework problem for you at home i think
this is a 2 it might be a 2i you should
check that i'm pretty sure this is a 2.
um
i'm going to go ahead and
assume that this is a 2 because the eyes
probably have already canceled out
but i would like you to verify
this property at home
and so just like e to the z has a
convergent taylor series everywhere you
should also confirm for yourself what
these taylor series expansions are for
sine and cosine of z and go through the
check to confirm that their radius of
convergence
is infinite that's super important
we also have hyperbolic functions we
have
for example cinch the hyperbolic sine of
z
is equal to
e to the
z
minus e to the minus z divided by two
hyperbolic cosh
this is the hyperbolic cosine or cosh
function is again e to the z plus
e to the minus z
divided by two and again i'm pretty sure
uh these are actually real valued twos
but you should just double triple check
that there's not an i in this
denominator
you could define the tangent function
and the hyperbolic tangent function the
same way and you should check where
those are or are not convergent
power series
a couple of good identities i think you
should know
just while we're at it are things like
i times sine of z
equals
cinch
of i z again that's really really easy
to verify here you should uh just verify
that i times sine of z equals cinch of i
z
similarly uh cosine
of z is equal to cosh
of i z again this is kind of like
because um of even and odd functions
remember if i take sine of negative x
it's equal to negative sine of x but
cosine of negative x equals just regular
cosine of x this is a very similar
property but with uh with the imaginary
number
um
and so on and so forth you can you can
verify more of these things like sine of
i z
equals i times cinch
of z
and so forth uh cosine let's say cosine
of i z
equals cosh
of z and then things like e to the z
equals
cosh
z plus cinch
z
and e to the z equals cos
i z
plus uh i
sorry minus
i sine of z this is a minus right here
so
this is a minus
okay and these are all things that if
you were taking a complex function class
like if you were taking a whole class on
complex analysis
this would be like homework one verify
all of these different relationships
check that the taylor series is
convergent everywhere
uh you know find out and derive all of
these uh these identities just so you're
really really good at manipulating these
again it's good to be able to manipulate
these quantities these exponentials
these sines and cosines and so on and so
forth
because these are going to end up being
the solutions of our partial
differential equations
for example sines and cosines and
cinches and cauches come up all the time
in the heat equation if i want to find
the steady-state heat distribution in a
rectangular metal plate i'm going to get
signs and cinches and cosines and coshes
all over the place so it's really good
to be able to flexibly go back and forth
between these quantities
okay good so this is just a small subset
of the many many many functions of a
complex variable
things like powers of that variable z
squared z cubed z to the fourth
you know finite expansions or infinite
taylor series expansions of those powers
which we hope are convergent everywhere
like the exponential and the sine and
the cosine functions
if they are convergent
if your function has a convergent taylor
series it's called an analytic function
and it's real and imaginary parts solve
laplace's equation i'll have a whole
lecture on that coming up
um
and then soon i think in the next
lecture i'm going to tell you about this
really really interesting function log
of z
which is analytic most places but not at
the origin z equals zero so this is a
kind of an exotic function but it's a
good example of some of the weird things
that can happen
in the complex plane okay that's all
coming up stay tuned thank you
you